[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi à 14
septembre vous regardez le 7 8 le
journal merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition on commence tout
de suite avec le sommaire
la course du vendée globe approche
départ annoncé le 6 novembre 3 illinois
qui participent nous avons rencontré et
le premier relais poste a ouvert dans
les yvelines en juillet il est à
montigny le bretonneux
nous verrons les neuf nouveaux services
dont vous allez pouvoir bénéficier et
enfin nous reviendrons sur la 7ème
édition de la journée nationale du sport
à l'école une journée pour promouvoir
les disciplines physique musculation ou
boxe athlétisme et est proposé
aujourd'hui aux deux élèves du lycée où
les rios attrape et on ouvre ce journal
avec le vendée globe la conférence de
presse officielle de l'édition à 2016
s'est tenue aujourd'hui à paris au
palais brogniart dont la salle 3 skipper
originaire des yvelines tanguy de
lamotte éric bellion et louis burton les
sportifs prendront le départ de ce tour
du monde à la voile sans escale et sans
assistance le 6 novembre prochain il
michael et demi d'euros les a rencontrés
ils vous en dit plus
tanguy de lamotte louis burton éric
bellion c3 yvelinois participeront la 8e
édition du vendée globe et skippers
s'élanceront des sables d'olonne le 6
novembre prochain pour ce tour du monde
en solitaire et sans escale jamais
autant divine one avait participé à la
compétition
la mère a pas de frontières
et on n'a pas besoin d'être né
près de la mer pour pour rêver à la mer
moi quand j'étais petit à versailles
j'étais sous la couette avec mes
bouquins de mer je rêvais de mer et j'ai
découvert la mer à l'adolescence et
depuis j'ai pas lâché et je crois qu'on
est beaucoup dans mon cas je suis pas du
tout un cas isolé il ya beaucoup de
divine oies qui pensent qu'ils pensent à
la mer qui rêvent de la mer les trois
événements des objectifs une expérience
différente sur l'épreuve tanguy de
lamotte participera pour la deuxième
fois la compétition en 2013 le verset y
avait terminé à la 10e place premier
objectif ça c'est une évidence c'est de
réussir à boucler ce challenge de
refaire le tour du monde le deuxième
objectif c'est mon objectif sportif on
vénère donc d'essayer de faire le tour
du monde le plus vite possible et avec
ce bateau là ça serait de faire le tour
du monde en 80 jours donc c'est un
objectif aussi assez symbolique éric
bellion seraient nos vies sur cette
course mythique après sa septième place
sur la transat jacques vabre en 2015 le
versailles et s'attaque à ce tour du
monde pour la première fois c'est
vraiment à l'arrivée
me regarder dans la glace et de me dire
tu as bien assurer ta fête a fait une
belle course et a donné tout ce que tu
avais
tu es allé au bout de toi même tu est
elle est là où tu pensais pas aller et
est a rendu les gens heureux est apporté
ton message de plus loin possible louis
burton de son côté tentera cette fois ci
de terminer la course après avoir
abandonné en 2012
50 % de la flotte qui abandonnent chaque
édition c'est un peu la statistique ce
qui prouve que
il peut vraiment se passer plein de
trucs les moyens modernes
ne permettent pas de deux
limiter cette case d'empêcher les
abandons j'ai pas pu terminer la
dernière fois donc j'espère bien que
cette fois ci ça pourra le faire et que
la malchance sera ailleurs les skippers
et guînois succéderont peut-être à
françois gabart vainqueur de l'épreuve
en 2013 en 78 jours record du vendée
globe
et c'est un service que beaucoup d'entre
vous attendent et aller chercher à sont
collés à n'importe quelle heure de la
journée c'est chose faite à présent à
montigny le bretonneux avec l'ouverture
d'un nouveau relais à poste il a ouvert
dans la nouvelle supérette coccinelle
express de montigny le bretonneux et
c'est là au début du mois de juillet
plus de problèmes d'horaires désormais
pour accéder au service postal le
magasin est ouvert 7 jours sur 7 de 9h à
20h plus de détails dans ce reportage
signé corinne fallait
récupérer c'est recommandé poster des
colis ou encore à franchir ces courriers
tous les jours de 9h à 20h c'est
désormais possible début juillet le
nouveau coccinelle express de montigny
le bretonneux a ouvert un relais poste
dans l'enceinte de son magasin davantage
les gens ils viennent et six sur
versailles sur cette épreuve d'affaires
des cultes des opérations qui font à la
poste 7 sur 7 pendant les horaires
d'ouverture des magasins pour accomplir
ses nouvelles tâches les employés du
supermarché ont suivi une formation pour
apprendre à gérer les services postaux
une initiative née peu de temps après la
fermeture du bureau de poste du quartier
du plan de trous pour les habitants du
quartier ce point poste représente un
véritable gain de temps c'est très
pratique ça évite de courir jusqu'à la
poste de la gare et c'est vrai que c'est
ouverts jusqu'à 20h et moi des fois je
rentre à 19h 19h30 et c'est vrai c'est
vraiment pratique de déposer un courrier
ou venir chercher son courrier ici un
distributeur de billets devraient
également être installés prochainement
dans le magasin actuellement 17 points
poste relais ont vu le jour dans les
yvelines
éducation à présent retour sur la 7ème
édition de la journée nationale du sport
scolaire unss des yvelines a organisé ce
mercredi 14 septembre des activités
physiques et sportives au lycée des
métiers louis blériot de trappes des
animations encadrées par des professeurs
de ps pour découvrir des sports proposés
dont les associations sportives des
établissements scolaires le directeur
académique et des yvelines serge clément
s'est rendu sur place pour rencontrer
les élèves un reportage signé nicolas
d'andré
les activités sportives en fait lui nss
des yvelines a proposé ce mercredi 14
septembre des animations physique et
sportive dans le cadre de la journée
nationale du sport scolaire pour ce
rendez vous le directeur académique des
yvelines serge clément est venu au lycée
des métiers louis blériot de trappes
objectif promouvoir les associations
sportives des collèges et lycées on a
grâce à cette manifestation un petit peu
phare en début d'année scolaire la
possibilité de rencontrer des élèves
d'aller à la rencontre des élèves de 2de
de montrer ce que ce dont on est capable
ce que l'on est capable d'offrir dans
les établissements et surtout de
provoquer une adhésion non seulement à
l'activité physique et sportive mais
aussi à des associations sportives les
associations sportives des
établissements scolaires permettent aux
élèves de pratiquer et découvrir le
sport en compétition et parfois de créer
des vocations il ya une bonne ambiance
le prof et apprend super bien faite aux
élèves et ça me permet justement
d'apprendre des sports de combat pour le
métier plus tard je vais m'inscrire en
club grâce à lui né cessent parce que
j'aime au niveau hélas évoluer quoi pour
l'année scolaire 2015 2016 près de 24
mille élèves se sont inscrits à une
association sportive dans leur
établissement certains jeunes yvelinois
ont réalisé des performances en ahl
tennis par exemple tous les ans ou qui
se qualifie qui sont champions de france
et qui vont même aux championnats du
monde scolaires
si les sports collectifs connaissent
chaque année le même succès des
activités en pleine nature comme le raid
se développent les sports comme la boxe
l'athlétisme le judo vont pouvoir
compter cette année sur l'effet jeux
olympiques de rio afin d'attirer de
nouveaux pratiquants
la police a aussi était en fête à
montigny le bretonneux une cérémonie
était organisée cet après midi pour
célébrer les 30 ans de la police
municipale en présence des représentants
des forces de l'ordre le maire de la
ville michel laugier a visité le centre
de supervision
ben il a également assisté à différentes
démonstrations des équipements
municipaux je vous propose d'écouter les
précisions du responsable de la police
municipale recueillis par nicolas
kirillovitch
montre aujourd'hui sur les différents
stands on est présent sur les
manifestations pour
proposer des actions de prévention ça
peut partir du vol de vélo jusqu'à
sensibilisation aux règles de sécurité
routière alcoolémie en fait on et voilà
on est on essaie de diversifier dans nos
domaines de prévention et puis bon même
sans avoir la certitude que notre action
swarm en définit des décisives et bien
contribué contribuer à une prise de
conscience sur certains faits et c'est
le rendez vous sportif du moment les 15e
jeux paralympiques sont organisés à rio
au brésil et ce jusqu'à ce dimanche 126
sportifs pros français participent à la
compétition dont un yvelinois oui radius
originaire du vésinet il a remporté la
médaille d'argent sur 500 m la médaille
de bronze pardon cette année quatorze
chaînes de télévision ont acheté les
droits pour la diffusion des épreuves et
plus d'un million de billets ont été
vendus un engouement sans précédent qui
ravit les sportifs handisport dans les
yvelines ils ont témoigné au micro de
notre journaliste michael almy d'euros
je vous propose les écouter c'est sur la
ligne de l'ombre en tête du monde dans
les stades
les gens semblent prendre plaisir des
athlètes sont top et on espère qu'ils
vont ramener encore plus de médailles je
pense que c'est une réussite ouais
j'suis pas si je suis mieux placé pour
le dire mais je pense que c'est une
réussite pourquoi vous dites ça parce
qu'on en parle je trouve qu'on en parle
beaucoup alors on parle un peu trop
comme toujours uniquement des médailles
françaises mais on en parle quand même
beaucoup et donc ça c'est bien et un moa
de football le tirage au sort de la
coupe de france s'est tenue ce mardi
soir au siège de la ligue de paris le
hasard n'a pas été favorable aux
yvelinois guyancourt qui évolue en
excellence sera opposé à drancy une
équipe de cfa2 cfa ces cinq divisions au
dessus des saint quentinois de son côté
à versailles affrontera saint maur club
de cfa actuellement premier de sa poule
trappe recevra le ca de paris à domicile
et vélizy jouera sur sa pelouse contre
champigny un club du val de marne enfin
le meilleur club yvelinois de la saison
précédente monde se déplacera sur le
terrain de la scène viennent de paris le
4e tour se disputera le samedi 24 et le
dimanche 25 septembre
et pour finir à cette information 50 ans
li bin sous les feux des projecteurs
l'agglomération est un nouveau un lieu
de tournage pendant deux jours les
équipes et comédiens de la série télé
est fais pas ci fais pas ça on tournait
les deux derniers épisodes de la saison
9 c'est la dernière saison de la série
diffusée sur france 2 depuis 2007 vous
l'ignorez peut-être mais l'un des
acteurs les lions du gua et lui-même
saint quentinois les équipes ont tourné
à l'intérieur de la librairie du pavé du
canal à montigny le bretonneux
on écoute tout de suite le regard le
gérant de la librairie
s'est fait par hasard en fait sont venus
nous voir en disant voilà on serait
intéressé pour tourner dans moins
clivant jusqu'à la forme assez atypique
et un schéma voilà qu'on connaît pas
beaucoup donc voilà on est intéressé
pour venir donc bienvenue chez nous on
vous avons donc on a ouvert la librairie
durant deux jours au tournage dont on a
bloqué toute une partie de la librairie
et c'était ils étaient une cinquantaine
de personnes entre la technique les
acteurs les figurants de l'avoir
appareils justement dans des séries qui
sont cons diffusion d'un terrien c'est
une très très bonne chose pour nous quoi
pour l'image chez les très bonnes choses
et c'est à présent la fin de cette
édition je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis je vous donne rendez vous demain
pour une nouvelle édition du journal et
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
[Musique]